- Mein Name ist Elkart Abdelmalek.
Ich arbeite als Gebäudereiniger.
- Ich bin Jannik Buchhorst, gelernter
Gebäudereiniger,
mit Leib und Seele bin ich dabei.
- Mein Name ist Ingrid Buchholz.
Ich bin seit acht Jahren
bei der Firma Clean Service
Power tätig als Bereichsleitung.
- Als Gebäudereiniger lernt man
Glasreinigung, Fassadenreinigung …
- … Graffitientfernung, Teppich-
shampoonierung, Grundreinigung …
- … und Schädlingsbekämpfung.
Das sind so die Hauptthemen.
- Bei der Gebäudereinigung gibt es
verschiedene Aufgaben,
zum Beispiel die Unterhaltsreinigung.
Reinigungskräfte putzen Büros,
saugen Böden
und machen die Sanitäranlagen sauber.
Die Gebäudereiniger haben meist
speziellere Aufgaben.
Sie reinigen Glasfassaden,
entfernen Graffitis
und säubern Teppiche.
Sie benutzen spezielle Maschinen
und Reinigungsmittel.
Mehr über den Beruf des Gebäudereinigers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.